with extraction 2 on everyone's Minds we
look into what the new action epic will
be about who's involved and how the heck
Tyler rake is still alive check it out
there's no denying that audiences love
extraction especially considering that
Netflix says that it's one of their
biggest successes of all time while the
film didn't get the best reviews with
only a 67 critic rating on Rotten
Tomatoes it nonetheless amassed a
devoted following of audiences eager for
a new action series that's why fans of
extraction have been vocally
enthusiastic online since the exciting
teaser trailer extraction 2 and its
teaser trailer have gone viral since the
trailer was released with fans posting
thousands of reaction videos breakdowns
and speculations about where the story
will go one person on Reddit pretty much
summed up the fandom's energy writing
Chris Hemsworth beating dudes to a pulp
with his fist on fire please inject this
directly into my body
after the announcement of the extraction
sequel the biggest question for fans
ultimately boiled down to whether or not
Chris Hemsworth's character Tyler rake
would appear in the film Hemsworth's
combination of acting skills combat
heroics and sheer star power played a
big part in making extraction the
success that it was and the movie
deliberately left the fate of its hero
ambiguous as we now know Hemsworth is
enthusiastically returning to the
burgeoning franchise with rake
apparently evading death he will be
joined by his co-stars from the original
extraction golshifta farahani as Nick
Khan and Adam Bessa as Yaz alongside
these familiar faces will undoubtedly be
a new crew of allies and villains we
know that the actors who have signed on
for the sequel include Daniel Bernhardt
and Olga karolenko among others
extraction 2 began filming in November
2021 just a year and a half after the
release of the original extraction it
wrapped in Spring 2022 and has been in
post-production for nearly a year and so
it begins
post-production on extraction 2. Chris
Hemsworth reported via Twitter that he
was back in Prague filming reshoots for
extraction 2 in November 2022. so it's
clear that this post-production period
was an extensive process fans will get a
chance to see the sequel to this beloved
action film when it begins streaming on
Netflix on June 16 2023 mark your
calendars rake fans
fans of extraction will remember that
things didn't end well for its hero the
well-intentioned mercenary Tyler rake
the character has an intricate backstory
rivaling something out of a Tom Clancy
book he began his military service as a
special Air Service regiment operative
in the Australian Army before
transitioning to private mercenary work
Drake's fate remains uncertain at the
end of the first movie when he is shot
in the neck before falling into a river
a mysterious figure appears before the
credit's Roland audiences couldn't help
but guess that Riggs survived it was
obvious that Tyler rake would be
returning if an extraction 2 was ever
made but it was unclear to audiences how
he could have survived his injuries the
recent teaser trailer gives more context
to the situation which brings rake back
to the land of the living a voiceover in
the trailer Speaks Over a scene of rake
getting hit in the head during a prison
outbreak recalling past memories that
provide helpful exposition
[Music]
you were clinically dead nine months ago
we can't wait to see how Tyler rake
survived his first extraction to fight
another day
it's been damn exciting
extractions struck an interesting
balance between high octane action and
subtle mystery surrounding its stoic
main character as the story peeled back
layers of his life as an Australian
Soldier and his complicated family
situation it became clear that our hero
wasn't always a cold-blooded Black
Market mercenary fans have been craving
more information about who rake was
before the events of extraction and
according to the recent teaser trailer
they're finally going to get some for
extraction 2 the filmmakers seemed to be
diving into the past before rake became
a full-time Soldier of Fortune using
flashbacks as a way to develop his
backstory there's been consistent
speculation that the story will feature
scenes set long before the events of the
main story to give glimpses at rake's
life as an sasr operator in Australia in
a way this has been confirmed by
Hemsworth himself during a discussion
about the extraction 2 trailer when he
said well this is all the flashback to
well before even the first film when it
comes to Classic moments in the action
genre it's hard to beat a good
old-fashioned prison break going all the
way back to classic films like the Great
Escape and Escape from Alcatraz these
films showcase classic obstacles where
characters have to break out of places
that seem impenetrable while the details
regarding the plot of extraction 2 were
unclear for a long time the recent
teaser trailer gives audiences an
abundance of prison break action that's
clearly a core part of the story The
teaser trailer takes place almost
entirely within a chaotic scene of
violent Mayhem as Tyler rake attempts to
rescue a woman from a prison riot the
scene is punctuated by rake fighting
hand-to-hand combat against armored
guards using Shields batons and even
Molotov cocktails according to the
official synopsis the prison in
extraction 2 will be an essential
setting for the plot the summary reads
after barely surviving the events of the
first movie rake is back as the
Australian Black Ops mercenary tasked
with another Deadly Mission rescuing The
Battered family of a ruthless Georgian
gangster from the prison where they are
being held you want to live longer do a
bunch of death-defying things that might
kill you extraction had a modest budget
of around 65 million dollars that went
primarily to its action set pieces and
on-screen Talent it's no secret that
extraction was a massive financial
success for the Russo Brothers as well
as Netflix when the original film was
released back in 2020 it ended up
becoming one of the most viewed pieces
of original content ever made with over
99 million households tuning in within
the first four weeks of the movie's
availability Chris Hemsworth even
commented on the popularity of
extraction in an Instagram post hey
what's up guys hope you're doing well
just want to say a massive thank you to
everyone who checked out extraction
you've made it the number one film the
planet right now this made it clear to
producers that extraction was a new
franchise that sells and a sequel will
need to go even bigger to up the ante
with all the main players returning for
round two there's a high likelihood of
that happening
Chris Hemsworth is a household name
thanks to his tenure as the otherworldly
comic book God Thor one of the core
members of The Avengers but that's only
scratching the surface of his talent
Hemsworth has proven himself to be an
entertaining and versatile performer who
can do everything from thrilling action
to gut busting comedy in films such as
Thor love and thunder black hat
Ghostbusters and rush I just start my
own team Team Four of course in
extraction of course Hemsworth leans
into the high octane actionist Tyler
rake in a near-endless stream of White
Knuckle chases and fight scenes while
it's clear that Hemsworth enjoys playing
characters with a bit of humor to them
he has also shown a significant
enthusiasm for returning to his
action-packed performance in extraction
2. during a recent interview with still
watching Netflix Hemsworth broke down
the film's teaser trailer saying I'm
excited for people to see the emotional
sort of story behind this character and
who these these characters were if Chris
Hemsworth is excited you know the rest
of us are too
fans might be surprised to learn that
the first extraction was the directorial
debut of Sam Hargrave who blew away all
doubts with an action-packed hit debut
having gotten his start in the
entertainment industry as a stunt
coordinator and stuntman Hargrave
followed in the footsteps of other
action directors like John Wick's Chad
stachelski taking his expertise from The
Stunt World and making action-packed
magic I'm definitely in my elements
while extraction was a big success for
Hargrave there was uncertainty about
whether or not he would come back to
direct the sequel of course we now know
those doubts were unfounded however
don't expect Hargrave to remain strapped
to the director's chair for all future
ragtails during an interview with
collider in 2021 Hargrave expressed
doubt about whether he would direct more
films in the extraction Universe he said
I would like to be as involved as
possible but I also don't want to be
greedy there's a lot of other super
talented filmmakers out there who would
have very unique visions and would bring
something new and fresh to the franchise
that I would be excited to see as a fan
despite this honest sentiment it seems
as though he couldn't stay away from the
franchise he helped create for at least
one more outing
in today's Hollywood there are few
producers who can match the success of
the Russo Brothers cutting their teeth
on wildly successful comedy shows like
Arrested Development and Community the
russos were able to prove their value
and pivot to directing mainstream works
like Marvel's Captain America the Winter
Soldier and Captain America Civil War
Not only was extraction produced by the
Russo Brothers the screenplay was
written by Joe Russo as well as more
information about extraction 2 has been
brought to light it's become clear that
the Russo brothers are as intimately
involved in this sequel as they were
with the first film and they're clearly
excited about the direction it takes
during a 2022 interview with collider
Joe Russo said it has a different color
schematic it's set in a different part
of the world it has a different pace a
different tone than the first one and
that to us is an interesting way to
approach serializing a story is that
it's more surprising and unexpected
as with most movies and development
since 2020 extraction 2 was heavily
impacted by the global covid-19 pandemic
the day-to-day aspects of traditional
Film Production had to be completely
transformed action movies require
significant in-person interaction tight
working spaces and the faces of actors
likely need to be seen without masks
production for extraction 2 began in
Earnest around September 2021 in Sydney
Australia however pandemic safety
requirements at that time meant the crew
had to make significant changes the
principal photography location was moved
from Australia and according to the
Sydney Morning Herald the Kofa delays
pushed Chris Hemsworth into scheduling
conflicts that jeopardized the shoot to
accommodate the timeline extraction 2
was shot mostly in the European cities
of Prague and Vienna rather than Sydney
as originally planned according to one
Austrian site the production team for
this soon to be Netflix hit actually
began filming in Austria's capital of
Vienna back in January of 2022 they shot
close to notable landmarks such as the
DC Towers in Dono City while other films
such as mission Impossible 5 have filmed
scenes in similar locations in Vienna
extraction 2 is considered one of few
big budget films to shoot on location in
this historic European city
if the Russo brothers are good at one
thing it's creating expansive universes
on the big screen after ushering in the
end of an era for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with Avengers end game and
showcasing the infinite nature of the
Multiverse with their production credits
on 2022's everything everywhere all at
once the Russo Brothers clearly know how
to produce a major cinematic event this
is probably why they have their sights
set on turning extraction into something
much bigger than a one-hit wonder action
flick during an interview with collider
Joe and Anthony Russo spoke about the
possibility of an extraction sequel they
discussed their ambitious hopes to
transform the series into a
multi-faceted universe of different
interconnected stories we're trying to
find more interesting ways to tell these
stories and across pollinate them they
went on to explain the worldwide appeal
of these films by adding I think what
makes that a compelling element to the
extraction universe is it is a global
franchise telling Global stories and
we'd like to diversify the point of view
in those movies